[Music]
hey guys before I start with today's
topic I wanna announce a giveaway we
will be giving away three $20 Amazon
gift cards at the end of the next week
all you have to do is be subscribed to
our channel like this video and leave a
comment about today's topic we will
choose winners randomly from the
comments section while we're waiting for
season 7 trailer which should be
published in the following days new
students and photos have been released a
few hours ago let's start with the most
interesting at the most exciting photo
among those new 7 photos which is the
nearest Targaryen mounted on Dragon
during a battle
now before I focus on a battle let me
just highlight obvious fact as you can
see in this photo dragon is enormous in
season 7 much bigger than the last time
is soem this is actually not that
surprising since a few months ago
director Matt Jackman who directed the
fourth and the fifth episode of the
upcoming season said the dragons this
year the size of 747s shagmon also said
dragon is the biggest of the bunch is
flaming 30 feet in diameter for all of
you that did not watch my previous
videos for all of you that are wondering
whose armies dragged on burning alive
let me introduce USS in a few sentences
in the upcoming season lady Landon
Tyrell the sole survivor of house Tyrell
will be betrayed by house Tarly of horn
Hill one of the most powerful vessel
houses who soar filty - house Tyrell
upon betraying their sown house randyll
Tarly the head of house Tarly will
become one of the new Lancers allies
which is not that surprising since
Randall has always despised the real
women beside Randall being awarded it
place in small Council as I've already
reported a few times the result of this
alliance is going to be Jaime Lannister
leaning Lannister army along with
Randall and Deakin Tarly leading their
Tarly army they're going to march on
Highgarden long story short
Jamie and Randall will outnumber Tyrell
soldiers and he'll conquer Highgarden
which should not be surprising at all
mostly because their army to lot number
Tyrell Army and also both Jamie and
Randall have a lot of military
experience especially randyll Tarly who
has a format
reputation of the general and is known
as one of the best battle commander's in
all of the Seven Kingdoms
however utter they are going to conquer
Highgarden and after Jamie allows lady
Elena to drink poison before getting
captured Jamie Randall with their armies
will march back home with carriages full
of ghouls floated from Highgarden while
they are heading home Daenerys his army
will attack Jamie's and Randall's armies
and take an opportunity to fight them on
the open field and to venture Ally this
huge battle will start with the track
ambush but during the battle the nurse
will also be riding dragon this battle
will end with a lot of casualties for
both sides but it's certainly going to
be the nurses victory during this battle
Randall and ink entirely are going to
get captured all bran will save Jamie
from mum of getting killed whereupon
they are going to escape and go to
Casterly Rock
the ancestral stronghold of House
Lannister that you're finally going to
see in the upcoming season if you would
like to know more details about
Highgarden and Casterly Rock
seeds of two great houses that we are
finally going to see in the seventh
season as well as the main reason that
will lead Cersei to decide to conquer
Highgarden make sure to check out my
previous videos however while Jaime and
Bronn will manage the scape in the heat
of the battle Randall and Dickon will
not be that lucky randyll Tarly will
most probably be burnt alive by Danny's
dragon as a result of his betrayal over
his Stern house Tyrell and for pledging
his army to the Lannisters well
Randall's sandakan Tarly will most
likely get a chance to bend the knee and
to swear fealty to the nearest weapon he
is going to become the new lord of the
horn Hill if you would like to hear more
details about this battle about the
death of randyll Tarly in the Linnet rel
feel free to check out my video by the
name season 7 confirmed deaths
there's also a photo Jon Snow either
leaving Winterfell as civil in the first
episode go to Dragonstone to meet with
Daenerys
or returning to Winterfell at some point
during the upcoming season let's
continue with a photo of Arya Stark
mounted up and on the road to somewhere
well her certain location is unknown
depending on the episode from which it's
taken if this photo is taken from the
scene which we are going to see in the
middle or final episodes of the upcoming
season it might be in the north at
Winterfell
but if this photo is from the scene that
we're going to see in the first episodes
it can also be in the river
in my opinion this is aria leaving the
Riverlands to be exact leaving Riverrun
the former state of house Tully is upon
killing the phrase she'll most likely
release her uncle Edmure Tully head of
house Tully and the Lord of Riverrun
who is phrase prisoner situated in one
of the south as voter frey mentioned
himself there's also a photo of Jamie
protecting the new ruler and if we can
even call her the protector of the Seven
Kingdoms which if you're wondering why
she is still by your side
why doesn't she finally turn back on
Cersei you can check out in my previous
videos as similar photo has already been
released a few weeks ago or you can also
check out material so explained by Jamie
will not turn his back on Cersei in the
first episodes but he'll kill her at the
end of the upcoming season name of the
video is new red wedding in season 7 the
remaining three photos are containing
Wendling Christie or more familiar to us
Brienne of Tarth on the set of
Winterfell either having a break or
preparing for the shooting then we have
Christopher gives you or more familiar
torment results on the set of Winterfell
and in the end we have Littlefinger and
Sansa Stark similar to a photo that has
been released a few weeks ago if you
would like to hear more details about
the nerves ambush on Jaime Lannister and
randyll Tarly or would like to hear more
details about lady lentils death or if
you would like to know how sensei is
finally going to start playing the game
and how the stark sisters will kill
Petyr Baelish feel free to check out my
previous videos for more details thank
you for watching and as always let me
know your opinion about all of this in
the comment section down below I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe our
channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace
[Music]